madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 21 juin jour
de l'été et de la fête de la musique
avec d'abord le kosovo et le désarmement
de l'ofce qu'à un accord a été conclu la
nuit dernière qui donne trois mois à
l'ofce cas pour rendre les armes
un accord qui ne suffira peut-être pas à
rassurer les serbes qui sont partis et
alors que l'on découvre encore de
nouveaux charniers dans la région avec
tout à l'heure le secrétaire général
adjoint de l'onu pour les affaires
humanitaires monsieur sergio vieira de
mello
la sphère dils dix ans après ça la
condamnation à perpétuité pour le
meurtre de deux enfants à coups de
pierres la commission de révision se
déclare favorable à la révision de son
procès patrick dils est en prison depuis
13 ans les 35 heures martine aubry a
soufflé son dispositif la deuxième loi
devrait prévoir une période d'adaptation
pendant laquelle les heures
supplémentaires seront surtaxés de 10%
au lieu des 25 % initialement prévu le
basket avec le début du championnat
d'europe la france fait son entrée tout
à l'heure avec des ambitions
raisonnables et un adversaire qui est
peut être à sa portée
le hasard du tirage au sort a voulu que
ça soit la macédoine et puis bien sûr la
fête de la musique avec comme chaque
année maintenant des milliers de
manifestations un peu partout en france
nous nous promènerons dans paris et nous
rejoindrons michel drucker et roch
voisine juste avant la spéciale tapis
rouge en direct ce soir sur france bleu
l'actualité de ce 21 juin c'est donc
toujours le kosovo avec la signature la
nuit dernière à pristina d'un texte par
lequel ou cheka s'engage à déposer les
armes avant un mois se seront toutes les
armes lourdes et dentelées trois mois
toutes les armes automatiques ainsi que
les uniformes les insignes bref loup
checa renonce à être une force militaire
au cours de cet accord signé entre
hashim thaçi et le général jackson vous
le voyez pour la kfor le général jackson
a dit qu'il espérait que tous les
commandants locaux de checa respecterai
l'engagement de leurs commandants
au même moment l'onu il sait son drapeau
sur l'ancien qg des forces yougoslaves à
pristina et les derniers des 41 mille
soldats et policiers serbes qui étaient
la province alors voyons d'abord avec à
on signifie ninja cela comment cet
accord et effectivement appliquées sur
le terrain
le reportage dans la région de mitrovica
la zone sous contrôle français
c'est le début d'un long calendrier de
désarmement
les personnels ou tce 400 fouiller
systématiquement à l'entrée de la ville
de gucci tom 90 jours ils devront avoir
rendu toutes leurs armes
même légère et par phase transitoire
pour le moment c'est seulement envie
pressante en compte deux armes de poing
qui ont été déposés par les personnels
de hisser qu'à désirer se rendre en
ville et qu'ils reprendront leur sortie
le chargeur de kalachnikov et à la
grenade
parce qu'ils appartenaient à des civils
même progressif cet accord de
désarmement chagrine sur combattre oui
je ne sais pas comment ils ont signé cet
accord on s'est battu dans la montagne
trouve que l'économie serbe et
maintenant on descend villegas et
contrôler ça n'est pas plaisant dès
aujourd'hui le général cuche commandant
le contingent français a rencontré les
dirigeants ou checa de sa zone pour
évoquer les modalités d'application de
l'accord signé cette nuit il va falloir
que nous voyons avec avec eux où ils
pourront mettre les stocker leurs
armements qui doit être contrôlé
également j'ai décidé de voir avec eux
où ils pourront définir quel village il
pour en définir la zone d'activités
libres car le plan complexe prévoit de
laisser aux débuts des zones lucetta
évoluera librement dans quel domaine
aucune action militaire
tout ceci suppose que lou checa fasse
confiance à la kfor pour protéger les
albanais cas d'école ce commandant
signale un problème dans le quartier
serbe mais il ne peut s'y rendent en
lui-même légende qu'on a reçues et
militaires venus checa ne peuvent pas
aller en quarts teisseire c'est donc aux
militaires français de régler le
problème en question ce petit barrage
établi par des cernes ne sont pas armés
ils portent des badges et prétend de
faire de l'humanitaire en fait ils
défendent leur quartier et risque
d'importuner les albanais passant ici
apparemment l'accord de cette nuit ne
les a pas tout à fait rassuré et tous
les jours on découvre de nouveaux
charniers au kosovo exemples de ces
massacres perpétrés par les serbes celui
commis dans le village de poclet qu'à
une quinzaine de kilomètres de pristina
là ce sont 53 personnes surtout des
femmes et des enfants qui ont été tués
et brûlées dans une maison la scène
s'est déroulée le 17 avril dernier les
hommes étaient semble-t-il partis se
battre avec le tchèque à dorothée
olliéric et raymond chaplin les
condoléances sont dérisoires
la tragédie de la famille mul joly est
trop grand mais ils sont venus pour
partager un peu de la douleur d'une
famille anéantie dramane est arrivé
d'allemagne hier six de ses proches ont
été massacrés c'est son neveu qui lui
explique le drame le 18 avril 1999 à 17
heures dans cette maison 53 personnes
ont été assassinées
cette adolescente est l'une des six
survivants
je n'aime pas bienvenus
je crois qu'ils étaient six ou sept
c'était des policiers serbes
il y en a qui a demandé à tonton sinan
et halte chan de partir avec
ils sont sortis et les ont tués ensuite
ils sont revenus ils ont fermé les
portes cassé des vitres et jeté une
première grenade
c'est à ce moment là que moi j'ai réussi
à m'enfuir en sautant par la fenêtre
les soldats serbes ont ensuite
dégoupiller une deuxième grenade fillon
vis des cinq chargeurs de leurs
kalachnikov sur les femmes et les
enfants avant de brûler les corps il y
avait 23 enfants le plus jeune avait six
mois
la plupart des restes ils les ont cachés
sur les conseils de soldats de l'otan
pour les remettre aux enquêteurs du
tribunal pénal international
mais pour que ce crime ne reste pas
impuni ils ont conservé toutes les
traces du drame
jusque dans la cave des femmes était
juste au dessus vous voyez les traces de
sang sur le mur
beaucoup de sang a coulé beaucoup ils
ont brûlé les hommes
après leur avoir tiré dessus mais comme
le record n'était pas complètement
brûlés et qu'on pouvait les reconnaître
alors ils ont jeté les deux corps dans
le puits pour ne laisser aucune trace
là il y avait mon père
ainsi avec marange
l'important c'est que le monde entier
sache et surtout que les dirigeants des
pays qui sont amis avec les serbes
sache que c'est le peuple plus barbare
au monde il ne parle même pas de
vengeance
les îles ont une prière ce que plus
acerbe le vivent selon leurs terres
sitôt après la signature de l'accord la
nuit dernière le président clinton s'est
entretenue au téléphone avec hashim
thaçi le leader de noche cas se serait
engagé à protéger les droits de toutes
les minorités au kosovo autrement dit
des serbes
et ce alors que de nouvelles exactions
sont perpétrées cette fois par les
albanais et que les serbes qui ont fui
la province hésitent à y revenir valérie
fournier
deux bouts
les olympiques ont visiblement de soins
de commentaires sur ce sujet que nous
vous rediffuseront peut-être tout al
heure deux soldats britanniques et deux
civils albanais ont été tués par
l'explosion d'une mine cet après midi il
était en train de procéder au déminage
d'une école dans les environs de
christina sur environ 50 mille serbes
qui ont fui la province à l'arrivée et
les troupes de la kfor et de loups checa
2000 sont entrés chez eux ces dernières
48 heures certains en revanche sont
restés sur place malgré la peur des
représailles
c'est le cas de neuf religieuse
orthodoxe d'un monastère de deivid dans
la vallée de la drée nietzsche à où se
sont rendus thierry thuillier et bruno
girodon c'est un coin reculé que
l'alliance semble avoir au premier coup
d'oeil oublier un monastère un lieu sans
auto ducks où vit une communauté de neuf
non serbes
les collines alentours c'est le fief de
lui c'est clair dans cette vallée de la
drée nizza où tout a commencé
ou albanophones et serbes depuis
longtemps ne veulent plus vivre ensemble
cohabitation dangereuse alors les
religieuses ont demandé la protection
des soldats français qui leur arrive et
des légionnaires qui ont pris leurs
quartiers dans la cour
mission insolite que personne au sein du
petit détachement ne voudra commenté
c'est la consigne
le monastère de davy tx n'a pas été
rasée comme d'autres mais le lieu a été
profanée il ya une semaine par un groupe
d'hommes cagoulés et en uniforme noir
une descente punitive
alors que la police serbe venait de se
retirer des environs ils ont cassé la
pierre tombale avec ces outils ici est
enterré un sincère les gens viennent en
pèlerinage prier et puis regardez ils
ont aussi endommagé ses fresques
elles ont eu la vie sauve les les
symboles religieux visés ne laisse aucun
doute sur les intentions des kosovars
les plus radicaux faire fuir les serbes
effacer toute présence orthodoxe au
kosovo le kosovo c'est le berceau des
serbes
il ya ici plus de monastères et
d'églises que dans n'importe quelle
autre partie de la série on veut vivre
ici simplement et on est prêt à rester
séparé les albanais depuis le 14e siècle
les religieuses de serbie et du
monténégro habite ses murs la mère
supérieure anastasia donc décidé
d'éviter restera orthodoxe un îlot dans
une région désormais peuplées par les
suns albanophone
avec nous en direct de pristina le
secrétaire général de l'onu pour les
affaires humanitaires monsieur sergio
vieira de mello
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes donc le
représentant provisoire de kofi annan au
kosovo ces problèmes que l'on vient de
voir des serbes dans la province est
effectivement l'une des urgences que
vous avez réglé tout à fait mais comme
vous le disiez la signature la nuit
dernière de cet engagement de l'ue ces
cas qui nous permettra donc de
démilitariser cette organisation est
très important dans le sens que lui ces
cas et fait évidemment la source
principale de souci pour les minorités
serbes qui restent encore dans le sud
dans le centre du pays
mais donc c'est là une étape très très
importante comme mais ce que vs que
trois mois ça ne peuvent apparaître un
petit peu long pour des serbes qui voit
autour d'eux ces gens nous checa
continue à posséder des armes
il faut lire l'accord très attentivement
dans une semaine très exactement les
militants de lui c'est qu'un seront tous
rassemblés dans des zones que des
terminales commandant de la force le
général jackson et par conséquent ne
pourront plus utiliser leurs armes ne
pouvons plus porter leurs armes dans des
centres urbains ni à 2 km des routes
principales du pays donc c'est ça qui
nous intéressait la kfor à partir
d'aujourd'hui et la police
internationale des nations unies que
nous commençons à déployer à la fin de
cette semaine seront chargés dorénavant
d'assurer la sécurité de toutes les
populations les rapatriés albanais ainsi
que les serbes qui restent encore et
ceux qui voudront bien entrer vous
disiez que 2000 et est revenu nous
encourageons les autres en faire autant
du conseil c'est suffisant pour rassurer
les populations penser que ce pari est
possible de faire cohabiter serbes et
albanais après tout ce qui s'est commis
ces produits que ce vous écoutez je
pense que oui sinon nous sommes nous ne
serions pas là cinquante mille soldats
3000 policiers des nations unies une
forte présence au civil de
l'organisation l'ol c'est l'union
européenne nous serons nombreux ici à
travailler à la création d'institutions
démocratiques au respect mutuel à la
tolérance
donc à toutes les valeurs qui ont été
systématiquement violées barthou et
saisi dernières années au kosovo et je
pense donc que c'est un pari qui mérite
d'être tenté alors l'autre grande
difficulté ce sont bien sûr les
exactions commises par les serbes de
même on découvre on l'a vu encore de
nouveaux chars ni tous les jours et le
tribunal pénal international et est
débordé est-ce qu'on a dès maintenant
une idée de l'importance de ces
massacres de leurs volumes si je suis
bien je crois qu'il faut laisser les
enquêteurs du tribunal faire leur
travail
vous savez peut-être que j'étais ici il
ya un mois donc tout ce que nous
découvrons à l'heure actuelle ne mettant
pas ce que nous avions vu ce que nous
avions entendu
il ya 24 semaines corroborait largement
les témoignages terribles
nous avons entendu de la part des
réfugiés qui ont traversé les frontières
internationales vers l'albanie vers un
mot sur johan bouquet se sont réfugiés
au monténégro il faudra laisser le
tribunal de faire son travail mais je
préfère que ce que nous avons vu ne se
répète un peu partout sur le territoire
du kosovo
une dernière question si vous voulez
bien vous êtes responsable de en quelque
sorte de mettre en place une
administration au kosovo en attendant
que que quelqu'un soit nommé
officiellement
vous n'avez pas peur d'être débordé
aussi par parle de chacun en tant que le
force politique cette fois ci je viens
de me réunir il y à moins d'une heure
avec monsieur thaçi dont vous parliez il
ya un instant j'ai déjà rencontré les
autres responsables politiques d'autres
partis
albanais serbe sur musulman et je crois
qu'il ya une volonté commune de
respecter les termes de la résolution 12
44 du conseil de sécurité qui octroie
aux nations unies la responsabilité donc
de gérer les affaires civiles
l'administration civile du kosovo à
titre intérimaire jusqu'à ce que des
élections donne la légitimité aux élus
du peuple kosovar
cette transition sera manifestement très
difficile
mille problèmes se posent à nous chaque
jour mais avec la coopération de tous
les partenaires
kosovars et également avec la présence
de cette force multinationale et notre
propre présence je crois que nous
réussirons
je ne peux pas vous en dire davantage à
ce stade
merci en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur sergio vieira de mello d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
à toulouse où il assistait à une réunion
du conseil général lionel jospin a dit
qu'il ne pouvait pas oublier ces
massacres commis par les serbes et que
justice devrait être rendu le premier
ministre a rappelé que la serbie devait
réintégrer la communauté normal des
nations mais que cela ne serait pas
possible avec milosevic ce qu'a répété
également monsieur clinton tout à
l'heure et puis enfin sachez que la
communauté européenne a décidé de
débloquer 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour le kosovo des
sommes qui ne tiennent pas compte bien
sûr de la reconstruction dans laquelle
l'europe aura un rôle déterminant
les algériens vont pouvoir plus
facilement se rendre en france est le
résultat de la visite de jean pierre
chevènement en algérie
la première d'un ministre français
depuis l'élection du président
bouteflika avant les événements 500
mille visas étaient délivrés chaque
année ce chiffre était tombé à 40 milles
au plus fort des troubles la france a
donc décidé d'assouplir sa politique le
commentaire de jérôme bunny sur des
images de notre équipe sur place
jean pierre chevènement à la conférence
des ministres de l'intérieur de la
méditerranée très attentifs aux propos
de son homologue algérien il est
question de lutte contre le terrorisme
et la criminalité organisée mais aussi
de circulation des personnes
le flux entre l'algérie et la france a
nettement diminué depuis le début des
événements en algérie et la lutte contre
les islamistes avant 92 ont estimé à 500
mille le nombre de visas attribués
chaque année à des algériens se rendant
en france
ce chiffre est tombé à 40 mille ans 95
pour remonter à 80 me l'année dernière
et à 200 milles cette année c'est ce que
vient d'annoncer jean pierre chevènement
il ya eu un changement de gouvernement
en france 1 et nous aurons une
conception qui lit je dirais la
facilitation de la circulation des
personnes de part et d'autre de la
méditerranée
en même temps le respect des règles
relatives au séjour dans le même temps
les déchets du consulat général à alger
sont modernisés et deux consulats
devrait être réouvert à oran et annaba
dans les rues de paris ces mesures sont
accueillies avec scepticisme par
certains algériens ceva pense que c'est
une équipe de ça c'est vrai
or a beaucoup qui vont profiter sur ça
mais si les algériens que c'est l'équipe
2 a une aura des visas pour certains pas
pour pour lesquels et squares aussi pour
ceux qui se bousculent dès 6 heures du
matin devant les succursales der algérie
les vols air france vers alger pourrait
être rétablie il avait été suspendu en
après une prise d'otages dans un air
pulsé la deuxième loi sur les 35 heures
martine aubry en dévoile les grandes
lignes au journal le monde il s'agit en
fait d'un assouplissement avec une
période d'adaptation d'un an pendant
laquelle les heures supplémentaires
entre 35 et 39 heures ne seront plus
taxées que de 10% au lieu des 25 %
initialement prévu le projet de loi
devrait être examinée le 3 août prochain
au conseil des ministres les
explications de pascal golomer il n'en
démord pas à sa sortie de l'elysée ce
matin après une heure d'entretien avec
le président de la république
ernest antoine seillière on veut
toujours autant à martine aubry et à ses
35 heures nous ne pouvons pas nous lui
entrepreneurs de france avoir un
handicap que les autres n'ont pas notre
isolement en europe c'est des gars est
complet en lisant le journal le monde
cet après midi il a pourtant dû lui
trouver un petit motif de satisfaction
martine aubry y dévoile sa seconde loi
sur les 35 heures et elle propose que
l'année 2000 soit une période
d'adaptation
pas de coups près donc concrètement les
heures supplémentaires entre 35 et 39
heures ne seront taxés que de 10% à
partir du 1er janvier 2000 après il
faudra attendre le 1er janvier 2001 pour
qu'elle soit taxée à 25%
histoire de laisser le temps aux
partenaires sociaux de la ministre de
négocier sereinement
ménard thibault était pourtant venu le
lui dire en mai dernier et la cgt le
répète ce soir une telle période
d'adaptation risque de compromettre les
créations d'emplois la cgt appréciera
tout de même que dans ce projet les
salariés payés au smic ne verront pas
leur salaire baisser
lorsqu'ils passeront aux 35 heures
un cadre qui ne peuvent pas compter
leurs heures la loi leur permettra de
bénéficier de journée ou deux demi
journées de congé supplémentaire quant à
la légitimité des accords sur les 35
heures martine aubry souhaite
privilégier ceux qui sont signés dans
les entreprises par les syndicats
majoritaires qui a déjà une tour de
faire réagir la crtc signataires de
nombreux accords mais souvent
minoritaires en marge de ce dossier des
35 heures le tribunal correctionnel de
versailles vient de condamner l'ancien
pdg d'une filiale de thomson
bernard que mon faisait trop travailler
ses cadres sans les déclarer reportage
d'agnès monteux et de jean françois
chaumette bernard roques mans avec un
surnom le patron au vinyle contravention
mais cet après midi le tribunal de
grande instance de versailles ne l'a
jugé coupable que pour 400 d'entre elles
l'ancien pdg de thomson rcm est condamné
pour avoir dissimulé les heures
supplémentaires des cadres de la société
des heures non déclarés il devra verser
50 mille francs d'amendé de sa poche
une première qu'il cherche à minimiser
on a trouvé effectivement pendant trois
mois où on a considéré que je n'avais
pas été suffisamment autoritaire pour
empêcher les gens de travailler voilà
c'est ça qu'on arrive là c'est ça qu'on
me reproche aujourd'hui ça paraît donc
extrêmement réduits à l'origine de la
faire il y à l'acharnement de cette
inspectrice du travail
elle va mener une véritable traque sur
le site d'elancourt siège de cette
filiale de thomson csf d'octobre 96 à
juin 97
elle relève alors toute une série
d'infractions horaires nos consignes et
heures supplémentaires non payées
l'inspectrice verbalise et les syndicats
se constitue partie civile
le pdg est poursuivi pour travail
dissimulé une nouvelle dénomination du
travail clandestin
ça veut dire concrètement que quand un
salarié fait plus de 39 heures 16 heures
doivent être ou récupérés ou payés
qu'ils soient où qu'ils ne soient pas
calme donc c'est la fin du soi-disant
forfait des cadres c'est la fin du du
soi-disant de ses heures qu'on peut
faire comme ça sans compter au titre de
la mission et c'est quelque chose qui me
semble très important au moment donné où
on est en train de discuter la loi des
35 heures
quel sera le statut des cas dans la loi
des 35 heures nul doute que ce jugement
fera école thompson rcm de son côté à
régler provisoirement le problème tout
simplement en installant des pointeuses
pour les cadres depuis une semaine les
usines d où près de longwy est paralysée
par la grève
à l'origine du conflit des
revendications salariales mais surtout
le mode de management à la coréenne qui
serait selon les syndicats un savant
mélange de brimades et de vexations
aujourd'hui les salariés se prononcer
par référendum sur la poursuite de leur
mouvement christine boss une entreprise
d'origine quand même importé en france
qui désigne la france ça prend du temps
d où a décidément du mal à se faire au
droit du travail français est au bout de
cinq ans de pratique il ne s'agit plus
de subtilité linguistique mais d'un choc
des cultures social depuis une semaine
80 % des 600 salariés de l'entreprise de
mont-saint-martin sont en grève pour
dénoncer le management à la coréenne les
gens qui rendent la maladie ou
d'accident de travail qui était placé
dans un service d'un service de que
j'appelais une réserve indienne où les
gens étaient
condamné à faire des travaux qui
n'avaient rien à voir et la production
d'entreprises telles nettoyer les murs
tel temps de gazon ou voire quelquefois
être enfermés entre guillemets dans un
bureau à ne rien faire en temps normal d
où fabrique ici des tubes cathodiques et
à quelques kilomètres de là des
téléviseurs et des fours à micro-ondes
les trois sites représentent 1700
salariés installés sur les décombres de
la sidérurgie
le géant coréen a bénéficié
d'importantes subventions publiques pour
son implantation 240 millions de francs
des directs pour le seul site de mont
saint martin aujourd'hui cinq ans après
l'ouverture de lusine des ou fragilisées
par la crise asiatique agite le spectre
d'une fermeture du site aux grévistes
les actionnaires de déhu menace si le
conflit se poursuit de fermer
l'entreprise à savoir de mettre en place
un plan social mais nous ne sommes pas
là pour savoir si la menace sera exécuté
parce que on appelle ça purement et
simplement du chantage à l'emploi
et ce n'est qu'avec l'entremise des
pouvoirs publics les négociations ont pu
progresser pour déboucher sur un
référendum à travers lequel les
grévistes se détermine en ce moment pour
la poursuite ou non du mouvement
les suites de la sphère coca cola la
société estime n'avoir fourni toutes les
analyses nécessaires pour déterminer la
cause des malaise survenu chez une
centaine de consommateurs en belgique et
en france et le secrétaire d'état à la
santé qui se penchent sur la dizaine de
cas recensés
l'usiné de dunkerque a repris sa
production à destination des pays-bas et
coca cola se lance dans une campagne de
presse pour rassurer ses consommateurs
yann fronty rassurer le consommateur
voilà le maître mot de la nouvelle
communication de coca cola pour
l'occasion un centre téléphonique
destinée aux clients inquiets a été
créée depuis jeudi soir
on a reçu ici plus de 650 appels
même démarche et même message martelé
dans la presse de ce matin
accusé de ne pas avoir assez communiqué
la firme d'atlanta passe à l'offensive
le discours est sans surprise et la
leçon bien apprise il n'y a pas de
problème coca cola parmi tous les tests
sur l'homme qui ont été réalisés et y en
a eu beaucoup
que ce soit par des laboratoires
extérieurs français internationaux que
ce soit par les laboratoires d'idées on
est toujours arrivé la même conclusion
il n'y a aucune anomalie aux produits à
la boisson coca cola ou aux autres
marques de coca cola ça c'est
l'essentiel
seul souci de taille les origines
exactes de l'intoxication et des
malaises de consommateurs demeure
aujourd'hui encore inconnu en france
une dizaine de personnes sont toujours
en observation à l'hôpital d'ailleurs
les inspecteurs de la commission
européenne français et belges devraient
se rendre dans les usines incriminé de
dunkerque et d'anvers pour tenter d'en
savoir un peu plus une situation confuse
donc qui profite aux concurrents du
géant américain fort bien sûr nos ventes
sont en progression puisque on à
multiplier nos volumes à peu près par
quatre depuis la semaine dernière depuis
les incidents pendant deux ans
voilà pour que quelques là les
conséquences de cette crise risque donc
d'être très importante
outre une image passablement écornée les
pertes financières s'annonce très lourde
certains experts parlent même de 20
millions de francs perdus chaque jour
par coca cola
dix ans après sa condamnation à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants à coups de pierres sur une voie
de chemin de fer à montigny-lès-metz
patrick dils obtient la révision de son
procès après avoir reconnu les faits il
s'était rétracté rétracter et l'on
s'était rendu compte un peu plus tard de
la présence sur les lieux du drame du
tueur en série francis pour le rire me
tirer kurt et et rémy poissonnier des
âmes et qu'ils attendaient cela des
années que les parents de patrick dils
se battent pour tenter de prouver
l'innocence de leur fils en demandant la
réouverture du dossier la commission de
révision vient de leur donner un premier
espoir
mais je pense que c'est bon tous sont
présents un mois et 15 jours 28
septembre 86 à montigny-lès-metz le long
d'une voie ferrée
alexandre et cyril huit ans ans retrouvé
mort tué à coups de pierres
sept mois plus tard un jeune riverain de
16 ans patrick dils et réentendu et
avoue avec précision les deux meurtres
puis il se rétracte clame son innocence
mais est condamné à la perpétuité en
1989 1997 la fair deal se rebondit
francis heaulme un tristement célèbre
tueur en série reconnaît s'être trouvé
sur les lieux du crime et avoir croisé
les deux enfants même s'il nie les avoir
tués
un élément nouveau qui a motivé cette
demande de révision du procès mais un
élément qui ne change rien pour la grand
mère d'un des deux enfants assassinés
fort pour elle c'est ce que patrick dils
est le seul coupable
j'en étais sûr que vous allez me dire ça
je suis convaincu de sa culpabilité est
tout seul et tout seul il a fait le
crime les deux crimes tout seul
patrick dils n'est pas encore sortie ni
de prison ni d'affaires la cour de
révision va désormais instruire et
décider si oui ou non le plus jeune
condamné à la perpétuité de france devra
être rejugée un jour le sport et la
première journée des internationaux de
wimbledon avec d'abord la victoire de
pete sampras le numéro 1 mondiale qui
s'est qualifiée facilement pour le
deuxième tour en battant l'australien
scott très peur en trois sets 6-3 6-4 et
6-4 en revanche défaite d'arnaud di
pascuale le français qui a perdu face au
britannique tim henman tête de série
numéro 6 côté français toujours retenus
les qualifications de nathalie tauziat
de sarah pitkowski et de sandrine testud
et puis celles chez les hommes
qualification également de sébastien
grosjean de fabrice santoro est en
revanche forfait de jérôme golmard le
basket avec ce soir le début du
championnat d'europe les français jouent
à domicile un avantage qui leur
permettra sans doute de se qualifier
dans leur poule où ils doivent
rencontrer notamment la yougoslavie
championne en titre et israël ce soir
ils font leurs débuts contre la
macédoine présentation de cette équipe
avec 2
guerre la france du basket ne jurent que
par lui tariq abdul wahad est le seul
joueur français à évoluer en nba le
championnat de basket-ball
nord-américain connu il ya quelques
années sous le nom d'olivier saint jean
il s'est converti à la religion
musulmane
aujourd'hui il revient sous le maillot
tricolore avec des ambitions
les trois enjeux la première place
champion d'europe
un pic à cibler et sortir les autres
parce que trop c'est trop
les gens savent pas se passer parce
qu'il reçoit de la feinte de passe que
trancher dans un sortir le basket
français de l'ornière c'est aussi le
souhait de jean pierre de vincent si
l'entraîneur peut connue d'un groupe de
vedettes
l'ancien directeur technique national a
su imposer son style à ses joueurs son
style et ses idées
depuis quatre ans j'essaie quand même de
faire en sorte que cette équipe de
france sur la vitrine du basket français
que pour le joueur lambda au cours le
supporter lambda ou pour le quelconque
dirigeant d'un d'un petit club
ils se reconnaissent dans cette équipe
de france que ce soit l'équipe de tous
les français devant son public l'équipe
de france voudra assurer le spectacle
pour cela elle s'appuiera sur un atout
de taille frédéric weiss à 22 ans il
était qualifié tient en deux chiffres
2008 115 kg jamais la france n'avait
disposé d'un pivot de cette envergure
quant au meneur de jeu il aligne les
paniers en italie antoine rigaudeau
porte depuis trois ans les couleurs de
bologne où il fait figure de star
avec lui la france espère atteindre son
objectif terminer dans les cinq premiers
de ce championnat d'europe et se
qualifier ainsi pour les jeux olympiques
de sydney en cyclisme sachez que
l'allemand jan ullrich a définitivement
renoncé à participer au tour de france
le vainqueur de l'édition 97 est blessé
au genou il ne sera donc pas là pas plus
que son coéquipier bjarne riis en
revanche richard virenque lui dont la
présence est toujours jugée indésirable
sur la grande boucle vient d'être
autorisé à participer aux championnats
de france
l'été est donc arrivé même si ce n'est
pas tout à fait convaincant du côté du
ciel c'est en tout cas le jour de la
fête de la musique avec environ dix
mille manifestations de toutes sortes à
travers la france pierre emmanuel luneau
frédéric basket et jean-françois hoffman
nous emmène pour une promenade musicale
dans paris
pour l'amour de la musique on tient du
bout du monde
pour l'amour de la musique on vient
aussi du coin de la rue là des vosges
600 élèves des écoles primaires
parisienne donné leur tout premier
concert
la nation c'est le rythme qui est à
l'honneur et pour ceux à qui la musique
donne soif bayal et ils osent line
servier du mans hier soir ça pête un
maximum
toutes générations confondues le rock
est donc toujours présent mais cette
année c'est la techno qui sera
incontournable
peu de monde encore cet après midi 6 mai
et comme il en faut pour tous les goûts
voici leur casque soit des gardiens de
la paix de la préfecture de police de
bas
il va y avoir de la musique partout en
ville
oui mais ça il va falloir que je meure
en stream et aujourd'hui seulement oh là
là alors on va s'coucher fois avec juin
à l'assemblée nationale et avec les
autres partout ailleurs la nuit sera
longue dans la visiblement tout le monde
n'est pas encore au courant
donc avant de rejoindre michel drucker
et roch voisine aller tour par une
maternelle du nord de paris marc perrone
est une star de l'accordéon en france ce
que l'on sait moins en revanche c'est
qu'il s'oblige une fois par mois à aller
à la rencontre des tout petits pour leur
part les musiques michel mompontet et
jean-luc melun d'habitude et les fans de
marc perrone nous sont plus grand certes
mais rarement aussi affectueux que ce
matin là aujourd'hui
le roi de l'accordéon est en effet aussi
le roi de la cour de récréation
une matinée durant il va avec c'est tout
petit racontait que la musique ce n'est
pas forcément sur une scène avec plein
de bruit plein de lumière la musique
d'un truc qui les concernent directement
que les belettes ce n'est pas forcément
qu'à la télé ou sur la platine de papa
je pense que que que que je m'enrichis
autant en faisant ça qu'en restant chez
moi jouer à peaufiner ma technique voix
doit préparer je ne sais quel concert
parce que la musique est d'abord une
respiration tout commence par là voyez
comme il respire
parce que la musique que se voit aussi
avec les oreilles le voyage avec deron
s'emballe vite
il leur suffit de fermer
ici on est bien loin des salles de
concert auquel est habitué l'artiste
c'est parce que les enfants aiment les
choses énormes peron fait dans les
normes et mon petit peron leur apprend
aussi que tout est bon pour faire de la
musique
même dans la cuisine il ya des
instruments des mamans qui va être
contente
avec modestie et tendresse et ron glisse
une fois par mois à ses enfants un joli
petit secret tout simple si vous faites
de la musique fait que la musique soit
aussi une fête
alors voilà justement donc michel
drucker et roch voisine bonsoir c'est un
tapis renard le spécial que vous nous
proposez sur france 2 il est en direct
avec bien sûr beaucoup de stars et comme
il est consacré à la chanson franco
québécoise michel il est retransmis
intégralement chez nos amis canadiens
c'est une première il faut dire qu'avec
céline dion et roch voisine
oui et dans une grande partie du monde
grâce au satellite tv5
il ya l'europe et à l'afrique et à
l'asie à l'amérique du nord francophone
et il y avait effectivement tout le
québec par tv 1 avec comme parmi nos
invités d'honneur roch voisine qui fait
son retour c'est un tapis rouge
exceptionnelle qui marque la fin de la
saison spéciale fête de la musique
franco québécois pourquoi bien parce que
jamais les québécois ont été aussi
populaire dans le monde de céline dion à
rock en passant par lara fabian la
troupe de notre dame de paris on va
parler de tout ça ce soir et rock c'est
un peu son grand retour puisqu'il est de
retour chez nous depuis quelques mois
ben oui je suis presque parce que j'ai
passé pas mal de temps déjà on a fait
presque tous les albums dans région
parisienne donc depuis je dirais presque
1,6 ou c'est moi je suis presque
parisienne là je travaille et je
travaille ici avec des gens d'ici
oui vous êtes presque parisien vous dit
vous avez enregistré en région
parisienne presque clandestinement pour
pas être dérangé par vos parents vos
fans
est ce que ça a changé le regard que
vous aviez sur paris ça change
oui déjà de pouvoir de d'habiter dans le
coin d'avoir sa propre voiture
ça peut paraître anodin comme ça mais de
pouvoir justement aller au marché faire
des trucs comme ça j'ai appris à
connaître paris et la région parisienne
d'une façon je connaissais pas avant
donc là je peux vraiment dire que je
connais cette région beaucoup fait
l'ascension il ya beaucoup de québécois
qui vous ont précédés qui habite paris
qui ont eu le coup de foudre et chris
ont pu repartir chez eux donc j'ai
peut-être la tête me garder
merci beaucoup à vous deux mois et on
sera en place pour trois heures bon bah
on sera avec vous un salon y voilà reste
à leur merci à tout à l'heure
c'est bientôt la fête la fin de cette
édition je vous rappelle les principaux
tétreault kosovo un accord a été conclu
la nuit dernière qui donne trois mois
nous checa pour rendre les armes
un accord qui ne suffira peut-être pas à
rassurer les serbes qui sont partis
alors que l'on découvre encore de
nouveaux charniers dans la région les 35
heures martine aubry assoupli son
dispositif la deuxième loi prévoit
notamment une période d'adaptation
pendant laquelle les heures
supplémentaires seront surtaxés de 10%
au lieu des 25 % initialement prévu le
projet sera présenté au conseil des
ministres en début août
voilà dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet qui nous allons
s'attendre au meilleur le suivi du tapis
rouge donc franco-québécois spécial fête
de la musique et demi par micha tauber
on vient de le voir le dernier journal
ce sera à 23h45 et mettez à zéro heure
25 les francofolies animée par jean
louis foulquier demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra marc blondel
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
pour revient bien sûr sur les 35 heures
à 13 heures ce sera bien sûr carole
gaessler et rachid arhab et je vous
retrouverai quant à moi à 20h bonne
soirée sur france 2 et bonne fête de la
musique